sí muchas gracias argentinas pues
primero que nada gracias por la
invitación sí es importante entender que
si claro estas sentencias de los jueces
afectan o si intervienen una política
migratoria y qué es una política
migratoria muy dura y ha sido
restrictiva don declarar y notoriamente
pues sí es importante y lo que se ve
desde sociedad civil es fortalecer la
protección humanitaria y la respuesta a
favor de las personas que es lo que no
se ve tan notoriamente pero que de
alguna manera sirve esta sentencia para
amarrar un poco las manos pero para
continuar una política pues de un
gobierno anterior si el gobierno de
méxico asegura que la permanencia de los
migrantes en su territorio busca mejorar
sus condiciones y añade que washington
se comprometió a atender las
preocupaciones de carácter humanitario a
qué se refiere puntualmente esa ayuda
que promete el ejecutivo de joe biden
si entiendo por lo que nos han hecho
saber los gobiernos que está viendo
activaciones de ayuda humanitaria por
parte de gobiernos vale la pena destacar
mucho que la ayuda humanitaria de las
personas migrantes en méxico
mayoritariamente la brinda la brinda
sociedad civil y entonces es importante
entender que bueno estos compromisos
entre los estados
queremos entender que aspiramos a que
hay una protección humanitaria del
estado mexicano a estas personas tienen
facilidades también para que puedan
regular su situación migratoria pero qué
bueno que al final no es la solución y
los tiempos de estancia en méxico llegan
a ser mínimo de seis meses para que esto
esto pueda pues para que pueda ser
atendidos no en este programa que sí que
sí notoriamente vemos necesidades
humanitarias urgentes
bueno y la unidad de política migratoria
del gobierno mexicano reveló que 882 mil
627 emigrantes han sido deportados entre
enero y octubre de 2021 con qué
condiciones deben contar los migrantes
para que no se produzca su deportación
inmediata
qué bueno que lo preguntas así es muy
importante entender que méxico como tal
no tiene medidas de regularización
migratoria existe la figura de alrededor
de la protección internacional la
solicitud del reconocimiento de la
condición de refugiado que te brinda
protección internacional ahí hay un
documento que emite migración que se
llama documento por razones humanitarias
que tiene ciertas características y no
cualquier persona en un flujo normal
puede tener acceso a estos entonces sí
es muy muy muy importante pueden ver
este dato estos 82 mil personas porque
lo que hace falta para que el principio
haya medidas de protección es que se
genere algo que
fomente la regularización migratoria de
todas las personas
señor talavera usted muchas gracias por
este análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en france 24